hi carmine welcome to another edition of
ask Evan in today's video I'm going to
answer your questions from when my
readers been who had a question about
creating an outsourced organization so
the email that he wrote to me
dear mr. Carmichael in Los Angeles
currently working on creating a virtual
company in advertising I've spoken with
a few ad execs that I feel that feel
like I'm crazy for trying to start a
virtual company I was researching the
topic and came across a Forbes article
and it hit me I'm not crazy I'm a
writer-director that works a bit on the
side in advertising it wanted to create
a client for a virtual company as that
no idea how this works the requirements
are necessary for the project I'm
looking for advice reading materials
suggestions or mentor thank you for your
time considerations been so bad help is
here for you
first office the entirely possible to
create in a virtual organization the
forks are called that feature of me I
spoke of all the people that I had
across the world who are doing different
projects for me and I'm almost
completely outsource everything that
happens in my organization the first
thing you need to do when you're
thinking about creating your own
outsource company is what is it that
you're going to do so think about your
skill sets what you're really passionate
about what you're really good at and
write those down that's what you're
gonna focus on everything else you
wanted to outsource to other people a
great resource that I would encourage
you to check out there's a website
called oDesk sets for outsource desk and
these provide lists of all workers
across the world who want to work on
different projects have different skill
sets that will complement what you're
really good at so if you need account
support if you need marketing support if
you need admin support you know the
technical support it's all there on your
desk what happens you can bid on a
project so you can put up projects a
here's a budget I had or I'm looking to
hire somebody who can
with my website and help me with admin
tasks people start to submit
applications and will tell you what
their hourly wages and you can often get
a pretty good rate especially people are
overseas and don't have this high
standard of living as as you might in
Los Angeles people will submit their
bids you can see the picture you can see
previous work they've done you can see
ratings that they have you can see what
tests it taking that they're actually
skilled that what they see they're
skilled at so you can think about you
know do you need someone who speaks
perfect English you're not getting
someone who has really good programming
skills or not and all those test
requirements are laid out your Odette's
you can then interview people and from
there it's time who you want to go with
an example for me I make these videos so
I try to upload a couple of videos every
week to my YouTube channel I've started
off doing everything myself to learn the
business to learn how it works and I
develop my own video editing and I
quickly learned that you know I'm not
the best video editing the best thing
for me to do is answer the questions
recorded all and outsource the actual
production of the video and so I'm gonna
go disk and I created the job posting
saying hey I've got a an opportunity for
somebody who wants to edit my videos and
I have a number right back there were
five who are shortlisted and I agreed to
hire everybody for an hour give them a
video and see what what they could do
with it see what I wanted to go with so
you have a chance to interview people
and also try them out if you'd like hire
them or short-term projects and one of
the real back a guy named Saad who I
ended up iris a piece of what everything
is this video I said and he wrote back
saying I don't charge for spec work so
he just did the project and I liked it
and I hired and he's been working for me
for a number of months and has worked
out great I just upload everything to
him and he sends it back to me final
videos all that it and it's great so
save me a lot of time I just created
some extra income and
likelihood for him and we all benefit
from it hopefully you guys gonna film
these videos as well so definitely check
out those oDesk as a resource for you to
be able to help build that virtual
organization the last thing I would
think about is remember that just
because you hired somebody overseas or
you're outsourcing some of your work
it's still something as part of your
team and you want to treat them like
that so you want to think about them you
know they're a person they have feelings
you want to just shove work on them and
expect it to get done you know try to
learn a little bit about them try to be
understanding when they have your shoes
so for people that I've hired and
they've been outsourced you know
sometimes they get sick and they're not
able to do work right on time or
sometimes announce comes up maybe their
computer crashes or they have a family
emergency
that kind of stuff is going to happen so
you want to be able to make sure that
you can support that you'll be
understanding and try to you know be
that team leader because you know when
you are faced with the situation when
you need something right now right away
super urgent which is going to happen
when you get in crisis mode you get a
lot of people on your team you can trust
will deliver for you so try to give them
a little bit of a break when you can
remember that they're part of your team
when they're they're only human and
they'll reward you with loyalty and hard
work and really care about the business
and care about working with you for the
long term so I hope that helps if you
guys like the video please give it a
thumbs up if you have any other
questions or ideas that you want to
share and also love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment below this video and
we'll stay tuned to the next episode